ALEXIS MOUSSINE-POUCHKINE:
Understanding cost
can be intimidating when
trying out a cloud provider.
And you may not be willing
to spend money just
to try things out.
In this video, we'll talk
about Google Cloud Platform's
free trial, and the
Always Free tier,
and why you should
not confuse the two.
Let's start with a free trial.
When you get
started with GCP, we
suggest that you sign up
for the $300 free credits.
This will require you to
create an account, if you don't
already have a Google account,
and to provide credit card
or bank account details.
The trial is free, and your
credit card will not be billed.
You will receive
billing statements
at the beginning
of each month that
detail how much
of the $300 credit
you spent in the previous month.
This gives you early
data points to understand
how much your future
service will end up
costing when running on GCP.
And it helps you see where
you're consuming the most.
You can also practice
budget management
by setting budget alerts
on your billing account
or on a specific project
that you're working on.
Keep in mind, these are alerts,
not limits, so pay attention
to where they notify
so you can take action
if costs ramp out of control.
Once enrolled in
the free trial, you
will be able to spend the
credits on the entire platform
for any location.
You are using the real stuff,
not some sandbox environment.
You are, however, not able
to request quote increases,
and you cannot mine
cryptocurrencies.
Sorry.
Things you should
try out include
starting your first
virtual machine,
transferring some data
to cloud storage buckets,
creating your first
Kubernetes Engine cluster,
running your Hadoop or Spark
workload on Cloud Dataproc,
or even training your own
machine learning model
using Cloud AutoML.
These are just examples.
The possibilities are
pretty much endless.
Note that you can create
multiple projects,
all attached to
the billing account
that has the $300 credits.
This could enable you
to try different things
in separate environments.
As you explore GCP and
come across questions,
we have documentation
and community
forums to help guide
you, as well as
a free trial troubleshooter.
If you have more
specific concerns that
require formal support, you can
purchase silver level support
using a portion of
your $300 credit
straight from the console
in the support section.
This trial remains valid
for 12 months, or until you
use all of the $300.
The amount of credit
and days remaining
are displayed at the top of the
Google Cloud Platform console,
as well as in the
billing section.
If you do use all the credits,
you will not be charged,
but your resources
will be paused,
unless you upgrade to a
paid account within 30 days.
You can upgrade to paid
account at any time,
and retain whatever's
left of the $300.
Once you do this, you
become responsible
for the cost of
your GCP resources.
Now let's talk
about the free tier.
Once you've upgraded
to a paid account,
GCP still offers generous
free tiers for 16
of its main products.
This is sometimes
referred to as free quota.
These products include App
Engine, Compute Engine,
Kubernetes Engine, Cloud
Storage, Cloud Functions,
our Cloud Vision, Speech,
and Natural Language APIs,
and more.
These free tiers allow GCP
users to use products for free
every month.
For instance, the first
2 million invocations
of Cloud Functions
per month are free.
And so are the first 60
minutes of Cloud Speech API,
or the first daily 120
build minutes of CloudBuild.
Some of those services,
such as Compute Engine
or Cloud Storage,
will be required
to use specific GCP regions.
As the name implies, Always
Free does not expire.
If you'd like to find out
more about the free trial,
or the Always Free tier, check
out the detailed FAQ page.
We hope that the combination of
the free trial, the Always Free
tier, and the simple GCP
pricing will enable you
to build amazing things on GCP.
If you liked this video, please
like, subscribe, comment,
share, and look forward to
more GCP Essentials videos.